Tyler Tyler one Stein camp is a league
of Legends streamer that became famous
for playing like [ __ ] I'm not gonna beat
intentionally because I don't want ban
so I'm just gonna you know turret dive a
full-hp anivia no I mean which is weird
because it's actually a pretty solid
League player voice you are watching a
challenger streamer how's it feel and
it's even weirder because his shitty
attitude actually broke soloqueue
[Music]
Tyrel one has made it to challenger a
matchmaking tier that's limited to the
200 best players in the region usually
made up of pros or pro player prospects
people who are being scouted because
they're just that good a league of
Legends but topper one wasn't exactly
Pro caliber but first of all Tyler one
was a one-trick he only played Draven a
snowball a champion that needs to get
ahead as early as possible to make his
game playable let's go I'm Tyler [ __ ]
one second and this is the important
part Tyler one was as toxic as it gets
[ __ ] so toxic in fact you can advertise
it on a youtube channel see title one
did play champions other than Draven you
kind of have to know how to play
multiple champions to succeed it lead
since your character could get picked by
the other team or band but timer one
didn't play other champions he ruined
games with them if you bans or picks
Tyra ones Draven or if you have anything
at all in the game that he didn't like
[ __ ] he'd run it down mid that meant
running an enemy champion killing
himself over and over again to give them
the golden experience they needed to
close out the game it's a miserable
experience because even the shortest
online League game lasts about 15
minutes between drafting and loading in
and actually playing the game someone
running it down mid effectively takes
away that chunk of your life he's
actually [ __ ] serious holy shiz like
that's the [ __ ] joke holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you're not having fun your
enemy isn't having fun and worst of all
one toxic jerk warning is now mid is
getting a duration from twitch chats so
naturally people started copying
easy patter one effectively found a way
to ruin soloqueue his toxic attitude was
highlighted by players like meteos and
hi and he even gotten a long strange
feud with riots community coordinator
and caster freak teller what's not
really that much of a personality though
like it's a nobody
it is only marketable skill of being an
[ __ ] like I think I think Freak needs
you know to taste what an alpha alpha
tastes like boys let's go all that meant
more stream viewers and more Tower one
fans copying him for last
ironically community figures criticizing
Tyler ones talks of behavior will be
made a more popular
whole time I'm just I'm just really
confused about how play like that is
just completely permanent instantly I
think there's something there's got to
be something wrong with the system
because there's always gonna be toxic
plays they put an eye on the toxicity at
the heart of league of legends and
instead of shying away from it some fans
embrace it together with his fans Tiger
one proved that there's a problem behind
League of Legends soloqueue it's a
system that requires everyone to want to
win but sometimes that's just not true
in response right issued an ID man
matter one I've been on twitch no I
still have that but banned from League
it's the harshest thing riot can do to a
player because it meant that they would
ban tower one anytime they found any
evidence of him playing League of
Legends riot please god damnit that
essentially killed his streams because
riot could ban is account the second he
started streaming the in thing
eventually died down partially because
people stopped finding it funny but also
because the toxic Vanguard had died on
his cross meanwhile Tyler won
entertained his stream audience by doing
this if a meal looks good on your plate
well it'll 100% taste good in your mouth
and this to another episode of
Tylar paints with prints and this for
the first for the first one I'm gonna
hit up is orange after I do I like I
said I got 10 more eggs I bought a dozen
boys powder one spent the better part of
2016 and 2017 trying to show riot that
he had reformed well I'm here to tell
you that that from Walter Wong calm you
can pick up your very own mouse pad
between hosting his own amateur league
of Legends tournament that drew in more
viewers than some EU LCS games and a
rider hurling some heinous insults at
Tyler riot found reason to lift his ban
in January 2018 it's [ __ ] true after
six hundred and thirteen days I can
finally finally lively legends without
getting my accounts back and Tyler ones
return to League of Legends on twitch
broke records for the most simultaneous
viewers on an individual stream that's
let's [ __ ] go baby these days Tyler
one purports to be reformed and to his
credit nobody found him running down mid
since his ban was lifted he even made it
back to Challenger with no complaints
from major players it's rarely said
while Tyler you are at Shout sir - your
[ __ ] player how'd you do it did Wow
maybe having League of Legends taken
away from him for all that time made him
realize that his in ting was taking
League of Legends away from everyone
else
whatever the reason though Heather one
story shows us how fragile the social
contract weaken League of Legends
players really is how one person with
two spinning axes to grind can ruin the
game for everyone also how wearing a
fake mustache in a Wonder Woman tiara
can break twitch records if you're
willing to put in hours of toxic work
huh hey hey yo V thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]